[Music]
[Music]
welcome to looper i'm brian rubin today
we are talking all about the marvel
cinematic universe
before 2014 if i told you that one of
the biggest superhero franchises ever
would feature a talking tree and his
raccoon buddy
you'd probably have called me a stinking
liar and yet guardians of the galaxy is
arguably one of the most popular marvel
movies
ever now i'm joined by tom and nina to
try and figure out the answer to this
question who are the weirdest characters
that could actually show up
in the mcu nina who are the weirdest
characters
that could actually show up in the mcu
this was fun to look up i found some
weird stuff
um so i think i don't know how likely
these are to show up but i
would not be upset if they did um i
really liked learning about thor's
sister
i believe it's pronounced lausa who just
turns into a fire demon at random times
um and and that starts when she's a baby
so that means we could see a baby
exploding into a fire demon with like no
provocation this is something you want
to see yeah that would be cool i'm into
this
all right okay um look i didn't know i
wanted to see rocket record groot and
like everyone has a groot funko pop in
their home so so baby fire demon is next
yeah baby fire demon is the obvious leap
um i feel like this guy's come up in the
good old looper slack thread but uh
armless tiger man could be interesting
armless tiger man who's that are you
guys familiar with eric hertz
no also known as armless tiger man um
yeah he was uh in the 1940s he worked in
a in a lab and there was
uh like his arms get caught in a machine
and he loses them
and he is basically like a tiger
yeah and he's super super strong
and he just like calls himself armless
tiger man
and um just runs around just wrecking
stuff
i have five questions exactly five
yeah uh i just want to set up okay so he
doesn't have any armed
no he does not have any arms and not to
disparage anybody but he's
also very very strong yes okay where
does the tiger in skip
leg day unclear as to where the tiger
comes in i think oh
he has like in all the depictions of him
he has like fangs and very pointy teeth
yellow with the fangs yep
um oh he like he got the
teeth to use in place of his arms for
more attack power
okay it's actually going to be six
questions who puts the teeth in for him
[Music]
i will have to direct you to my
forthcoming book armless tiger man
biography that i'm currently working on
reserving it on amazon finally if you
don't mind i'm sorry to keep
interrupting but i'm very excited about
this subject
which hero pulled the short straw on
this one who who
who's whose nemesis is armless tiger man
black panther oh that's sad
it is he's he's another big cat with
arms
yeah he does have arms so that's an
immediate disadvantage but you know if
say shuri dons the suit maybe she has to
fight an armless tiger man
in doing so that doesn't feel better
she's a very smart woman
she's got like a lot going
you're concerned about the armless tiger
man you're worried about his his
well-being
i'm nothing but concerned about the army
man
this is working
so then this is working i'm drumming up
sympathy in this character it's already
working
um and my final uh my final one is uh
ruby thursday
are you guys familiar with her no
she is yeah did you fall asleep under
too many blankets where are these coming
from
these are straight out of marvel.com she
is
basically like she is part of like the
head man or something
and she has a plastic head like mr
potato head where she can move stuff
around on it
sometimes she just turns into an
enormous pair of plastic lips
and then she fights who does she
oh and then she fights okay uh she she
fights with she fights uh
she-hulk and then she also fights the
avengers and the x-men later
it feels like there's a lot of
incongruous match-ups
yeah happening okay oh yeah yeah you got
it she finds a surprising amount of
people
ruby thursday i think whatever is i
think the reason she fights a lot of
people is because when you start working
at marvel comics and you go
i i need i need them to be able to beat
someone really quickly in the first two
pages of this issue before we get to a
real villain they're like
oh yeah ruby thursday just throw her in
getting arrested
like she's already been beaten before
the reader has shown up
she can be like you know like baron zemo
was for a while just kind of floating
around doing nefarious stuff in a bunch
of different movies
but never like rarely being the main
antagonist while also occasionally
rearranging her face
yeah right this is that's head on a hat
but i love it
i feel like ruby thursday is unlikely to
make an appearance
i agree but i'm glad i don't dream yeah
i just want
everyone to know that she she's out
there waiting a strong
female antagonist yeah marvel
it's time coming you asked for weirdest
you asked me for weirdest and i feel
like i really
okay i have eight questions
okay why is your name movie thursday
uh it's like it's a reference for the
rolling stone song ruby tuesday
but i don't know why there's nothing
that doesn't matter
i don't know why keith richards never
sings
hello ruby thursday she was always lost
in time and space
no that's that's the only explanation
that there is it's just like
she's just ruby thursday and it's a it's
a rolling stones reference but they're
never like
and here's the meaning behind it she's a
woman of mystery
thomas i smell it i guess
well i'm in love with her tom
put your love away just for a minute i
don't know if i have that in me but i'm
gonna
give it at the old college who are the
weirdest
villains or weirdest characters excuse
me
that the mcu could bring in and face for
so i feel like we've got all the
classics you know the the people that
are just going to come up any time being
google like weirdest
weirdest marvel characters you get your
great lakes avengers you got your uh
you you you got your pet avengers you
got those those groups
uh i don't know there's a lot of guys
that haven't gotten a lot of
attention for good reason
uh slapstick was one of my favorites
when i was a kid
character you remember slapstick he's
great i remember from the marvel comics
cards i had the trading cards
so i remember getting that card and
saying slapstick
the hell was that yeah yeah okay yeah
and then like moving on to like
nightcrawler and the
heroes right yeah yeah he was very much
a uh
what is the batman what does he do the
lava blast batman
yeah of of trading cars he's the one
that you didn't really want but you're
like oh that's
yeah i don't know uh what does he do he
he has all the powers basically with
texas avery
though he's he's he's uh he looks like a
chuck jones character
he's out there getting squashed by uh by
steamrollers and stuff
he's uh he pulls a giant mallet out of
nowhere he's a he's a big old silly goof
so the max starring jim basically you
know what i would be
a little bit flabbergasted if it turned
out that this character didn't pop up
right after the mask starring jim carrey
yeah yeah oh that makes sense
yeah but fun uh who else what did we get
um like two-thirds of alpha flight i
feel like would be very weird to see on
screen
uh alpha flight's pretty strange alpha
flight is
top tier to me but like it is
inescapable that the vast majority of
the roster is made up of
racial stereotypes and problematic
archetypes and
uh yeah there's that like i think puck
spent like the first
five or six years that he was a
character just being like funny because
he's shorter than everybody
like that was his entire defining
character right
well on behalf of short people
everywhere that's insulting well
and on behalf of the rest of the heroes
look at your goal
good job all right so uh
let's see here uh oh that version of
nixon that shot himself from the captain
america comic back in the day i don't
know if you guys remember that
it was like they kept him like really
shadowy and stuff but he like he just
full on he uh no he swallows a bullet
right there on
on the page so that's one of your picks
for weirdest characters they could bring
in
yeah that version of nixon that shot
himself in the captain america comic is
my number three pick
uh actual bucky from the comics i feel
like instead of like the reimagined
version like the one that is inarguably
a 14 year old with machine gun i would
love to see that on screen
uh and then finally uh henry cavill
superman
that would be pretty weird yeah that
would be
weird yeah what if oh but just to spring
off of that what if they did squadron
supreme
what if they did and cast henry cavill
cavill excuse me
i don't know what's that dude's name
who's the leader of the squadron supreme
oh shoot they're the jla analogs
in the marvel comments that's it's not
century is it is it hyperion
maybe it sounds right i think i think
let's just cut out this part where none
of us know anything
is it hyperion it might be hyperion i
think that's who it is
i can't keep all of the like dark
reimaginings of superhero straight
anymore
it's a little difficult um so my pick i
also
thought of the the great lakes avengers
um
i like squirrel girl a lot oh yeah
squirrel girl is a favorite they were
actually going to bring squirrel girl
into the mcu at some point a few years
ago they announced
a show that they were going to put on tv
that was going to be part of the mcu
with moana vain trub as squirrel girl
that didn't happen she does the voice
on the in the cartoon but my
pick for the weirdest villain that they
could bring into the mcu
that i think could actually show up in
the mcu at some point
is swarm are you familiar with swarm
i'm not tom are you familiar with swarm
i'm thinking of the thousand i think who
are you talking about
swarm is a nazi scientist
nope who is also
a person-shaped swarm of bees in a
purple cape with white gloves
and wait he wears a cape he wears a
purple cape with a hood
over his mound of his
head he has teeth
rocket raccoon among many other
characters
um he fought the champions which was
a bunch of heroes out in la that was
comprised of
uh i want to say season hercules iceman
ghost rider angel black widow
and someone named darkstar who i'd never
heard of before
until i started looking into swarms
origins
but swarm is a former nazi scientist who
escaped
to i want to say south america central
america
and he was out there doing research on
being a nazi
and he's like researching bees
well he's like i need i need bees to
take over the world
but look look at these bees and he says
a comet hit the earth recently and i
think these bees were affected by that
comet
if i can control these bees
i can take over the world and so he
builds a ray gun shoots the bees
and learns that he wasn't able to
control the bees but he was able to make
them very angry so they swarm him
i am captivated right now sting him like
crazy
and then his consciousness is shredded
and is spread across the bees
and he's now a pile of bees
shaped like a guy and he fights the
champions
and they beat him by hercules throws the
queen bee
into the into the ocean
and so then all the bees leave and then
all that's left is a pile of bones
this sucks so hard he's come back
he's come back since then um
swarm well yeah you don't just throw
away a character like nazi scientist who
got stung by a bunch of bees
he's nazi bees sworn a bunch of nazi
peach
he's nazi bees i'm broken you've broken
me with this information
so there's swarm so that's who i want i
too i think is the weirdest character
that they could bring into the mcu that
i think
would be great why not we've got can you
imagine being like a racial
like superiority based
fill-in and then going like you know you
know what it's probably fine if i'm a
bunch of bees
i got a lot of problems with different
skin colors and lifestyles but i think
as long as i'm white bees
i should be fine oh my god
they're so they're bees bees sworn
oh my god yeah i want i i want i want to
swarm movie i want to swarm franchise i
want to swarm action figure i want to
perform everything you can buy a swarm
action figure
i want i want to see 20 000 bees line up
at a salon to get their hair peroxided
and bees are nice he should have been
wasps
yeah washable berries yeah
yeah these are helpful they're saving
the planet yeah
we we like these we like them we here at
looper support bees
that seems like a natural conclusion
point for the episode yes
save the bees thank you you know we hate
a lot of things here at looper
not bees good night
thanks for joining us please hit like
and subscribe so you don't miss a single